[Music]
my bad investment strategy that i hear
often right now
and this is gonna sound weird because
i'm doing the milk road clearly i'm
bullish on crypto
is um
i'm gonna give you two categories one is
nfts in general
um i think that
so much money is gonna be lost
and made but lost the losses will out
far outweigh the gains um for for in
nfts uh when we look back like five
years from now
um
i think it is nuts what people are doing
with nfts uh they would you know like
um
if you if you basically just described
the same asset class but without the
word nft
um
you know you would you'd say like yeah
cool how much money are you putting into
baseball cards how much are you putting
into you know
works of art how much how much money are
you putting to these why do you believe
that this digital art that you put this
picture of a penguin you bought is the
better investment than those or how
about let's just simplify it
i'm going to give you 15 seconds to
describe why you bought this nft and the
only thing you're not allowed to say is
that i think it might go up right and
like you know the the answer for most
people is this sucker's going up right
and then the second worst answer they
give you is the community it's like oh
you really you bought it for the what
does that mean what is the community
tell me about this community oh it's a
community of people who all want this
sucker to go up oh cool so you're all
cheering for the same you know like you
know greater full outcome and so i think
for a huge number of obviously there's
going to be winners in nfts right people
are going to do well um
some projects also
if you like it buy it
yeah
if you're literally buying because you
like the picture of the art
and you really want to own
that penguin fantastic
but be honest with yourself almost
everybody who's doing it right now is
doing it because they think you know i'm
hoping that this is the next one that
goes up like crazy
and um
just call it what it is if it's a
lottery ticket it's a lottery ticket and
just say you're buying lottery tickets
for you know thousand dollars pop and uh
if that's really what you want to do do
it but i just think it's generally quite
a bad strategy
for people to do you were the first one
who told me about nfts and you bought
one that i thought was awesome and i'm
not even a basketball fan but you bought
this kobe one and he like was dunking
and turning into an angel and i was like
oh that's pretty awesome that's sick um
but you sold it and you made a profit
like ten thousand dollars in profit
right
yeah i bought it for maybe like i don't
know six hundred eight hundred dollars
and then i sold it for ten ten grand
like a month later what's it worth now
it trades for about twenty five hundred
dollars now
um
and i actually the reason i i actually
think that might be an nft i'm like
proud of that one that was a just for to
learn and be i thought the art was cool
but i thought that was so cool that i
almost went back and bought it again
yesterday i was like
i actually really like this like this is
just a really cool i agree a piece of
art and um this time if i buy it it's
not to you know learn or to see if it'll
go up it's because i actually like this
one but i have so many other nfts in my
my like in a wallet that are just like
you know
you know i bought it because hey maybe
this is going to be the next one that
people pour their money into and i get
this fabulous run-up um but those are
scratch-off tickets and like do i really
want to be buying 300
dollar that eight hundred dollar scratch
off tickets like
seems like a pretty bad idea it seems
like it's not investing at all actually
it shouldn't even be called an investing
strategy how much money um what what i'm
i sound so ignorant what's the w when
you say that like when someone says um
you know they've bought uh a thousand
dollars of bitcoin although it's now
worth a million dollars what do you call
the thousand dollars your uh
your basis yeah your basis so what was
your basis for um
how much did i put into nfts yeah
so these uh probably in total maybe like
five grand stuff like that five ten
grand i didn't buy any of the like super
expensive nfts
um
and uh yeah so you know i did well
because i
early on there was this thing called
nifty gateway and they were doing
curated drops so it was like one of the
good things that around was like
yeah yeah they're doing well still um so
that's where the kobe one came out of
there's this artist that i had followed
for a long time it's got bosslogic he
makes all the ufc posters so you've
you've definitely seen this stuff
because uh
um he's like joe rogan will repost his
stuff uh from time to time so he boss
logic did the kobe one so that's why i
was like oh i actually like this artist
i follow him i've bought like uh you
know like a print of his before
i'll buy his nft so that was a good move
and then the other one then i got caught
up in the hype and bought like five of
of this like thing called the aku
um it's just like a whatever you can
google it
aku
and uh i bought those just thinking like
oh are these all just like you know
positive flips and so i bought five of
them for i want to say like 700 each and
then i've sold four of them
uh each one for about fifteen hundred
dollars now two to two thousand dollars
so i basically like doubled my money on
four of them um and then i kept the last
one just to like just to own basically
um so i did well with those and then i
have other ones in my wallet that like
you know i bought for
a few hundred dollars and they're worth
i think zero like i think they literally
like you could not i could not give it
away if i wanted to just give it away to
somebody our friend so nobody would pay
the gas fee to pick it up our friend
jack was selling a uh
it was like a lock box it was like a box
that was like and after you bought it it
would be unveiled like what the art was
and i thought that was actually kind of
neat uh i'm not like jack's my homie i'm
not like if it was like if i was like
someone who's like i'm a true fan of
where i was like i'd be honored to own
anything you've made then maybe i could
see myself doing that but people were
doing that with him and it was pretty
amazing
yeah yeah i think nfts are cool they're
gonna have a place i just think that
most the way that most people are
investing in them right now is scratch
off lottery tickets and i think that
that's a bad strategy
[Music]
you